vor der amerikanischen westküste geht
etwas seltsames vor sich schon seit
einiger zeit entweicht dort massenweise
methan und zwar aus hunderten von
quellen auf dem meeresgrund diese blasen
entweichen genau in der region die
tektonisch gesehen zu den gefährdetsten
der ganzen welt gehört sind sie die
vorwarnung eines riesigen erdbebens
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich faszinierendes heinz videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen die
gasströme entweichen aus der sogenannten
cascadia subduktionszone
diese region ist bekannt als hochrisiko
gebiet für die vielleicht krassesten
erdbeben weltweit in einem abstand von
wenigen in jahrhunderten kommen hier
schwere erdbeben mit verheerenden folgen
vor das letzte mega beben fand im januar
1700 stadt ein gigantischer tsunami war
die folge heutzutage ist region dicht
besiedelt denken wir beispielsweise an
den ballungsraum vancouver seattle
portland mit millionen von einmal ein
schweres erdbeben hätte katastrophale
folgen denn wirklich erdbebensicher
gebaut wurde erst ab den 80er jahren die
erklärung für das entstehen von erdbeben
in dieser region ist super einfach denn
in dieser cascadia subduktionszone
treffen kontinentale und ozeanische
kosten platten aufeinander
die folge sind dann sogenannte
subduktionszone die stärksten erdbeben
überhaupt auf der richterskala erreichen
solche erschütterungen magnitude 9 oft
dauert das ganze länger als eine minute
und den schätzungen zufolge entspricht
die freigesetzte energie dem einschlag
eines ein kilometer großen asteroiden
was passiert hier genau durch diese
kollision der kontinentalen und der
ozeanischen platz wird die ozeanische
kruste in den erdmantel gedrängt der
kontinent wird an der subduktionszone
zusammengeschoben und die vorderste
kannte volk der absinkenden platte in
die tiefe
die größte dahinter wölbt sich auf und
ist gespannt wie eine feder
irgendwann wird die spannung aber zu
groß und die kontaktfläche schnell in
die ausgangslage zurück dabei wird dann
das wasser darüber verdrängt und eine
gewaltige welle entsteht die sich in
richtung der küste bewegt doch nicht nur
diese krasse energie ist typisch für die
prozesse der subduktion beben
daneben auch dass sie relativ regelmäßig
auftreten
deshalb sind forschungsteams mit
hochdruck dabei die beschaffenheit des
meeresgrundes in dieser region besser zu
verstehen
eine wichtige hilfe könnten den methan
blasen seien die seit einiger zeit vor
der amerikanischen westküste entweichen
schon 2009 wurden die ersten methan
austritt vor der küste des bundesstaates
washington aufgespürt noch was der
forscher paul johnson jetzt mit seinem
team entdeckt hat überrascht selbst die
fachleute wenn man dem meeresgrund von
vancouver island bis zum vollen wäre für
entlang gehen soll dann wäre man nie aus
versuchsweise ein abladen wollte heißt
also im klartext der kontinentalhang vor
der us-küste ist übersät von solchen
methan austreten
insgesamt 491 cluster werden durch 1778
gasquellen auf dem meeresgrund rund 50
kilometer von der küste gebildet das
aufspüren solcher methan fällen
funktioniert übrigens nicht nur mit sehr
speziellen messverfahren sondern auch
mit einer anderen eher kuriosen methode
und zwar durch die analyse von
satellitendaten das forschungsteam weist
darauf hin dass ich häufig eine große
anzahl an fischerbooten um die
austrittsstelle von methan bilden der
grund dafür ist einfach fische sind dort
auf der suche nach lebewesen die
wiederum mikroorganismen fressen und
diese wiederum bedienen sich an methan
der aktuellen analyse zufolge befinden
sich die methanquellen in einer tiefe
von etwa 160 metern auf einem schmalen
streifen von maximal zehn kilometer
breite und zwar genau an der stelle an
der sich die sogenannte ozeanische
hundefutter platte unter die
nordamerikanische kontinentalplatte
schiebt durch diesen prozess werden
sedimente abgeschabt und zwischen den
platten zusammengedrückt dabei wird
methan herausgedrückt und entweicht in
form von blasen aus dem meeresboden eine
weitere erkenntnis die methan blasen
treten er im flachen wasser auf das
alles lässt das us forschungsteam
vermuten dass die platten bei einem
starken erdbeben in der region
übereinander geschoben werden und dabei
brüche entstehen durch die das methan
nach und nach entweichen dazu johnson
die risse in dieser tektonischen grenze
liefern die pfade durch die das
methangas und warme flüssigkeit aus dem
tiefen entweichen kann
beim beben des meeresbodens im flachen
wasser nahe der küste könnte man also
einen kleineren zusammen mehr erwarten
als beim beben das im tiefen wasser
stattfindet spricht die methan austreten
können die vorboten eines grossen bebens
seien und betroffen davon kann die
komplette us westküste seien das heißt
nicht dass das erdbeben auf einmal
überall auftritt aber dass im laufe der
jahre den gesamten us westküste
betroffen sein können in los angeles und
san francisco wird ja schon länger ein
großes beben befürchtet mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit wird es im laufe der
nächsten 20 jahre stattfinden
die methan blasen im norden könnten der
vorbote einer verkettung von erdbeben
seien es wird mit zehntausenden toten
und milliardenschäden gerechnet und es
wird aus heiterem himmel kommen niemand
kann es genau vorhersagen da helfen auch
nicht die methan blasen mehr zum thema
tsunamis einfach erklärt anklicken
anschauen und natürlich raumzeit block
der zukunft abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran